[Música]
[Aplausos]
si quieres cambiar el mundo cámbiate a
ti mismo cuantos están de acuerdo con
esta frase
ante la pregunta de que si las personas
pueden cambiar respondo rotundamente por
supuesto que si los cambios son procesos
que toman su tiempo donde la mayor parte
de las veces pueden ser dolorosos
incómodos y nos producen hasta miedo ya
que la mayoría de las veces esto se
requiere que nos desprendamos de cosas
que no nos permiten avanzar pero es que
los cambios no ocurren de una manera
mágica o automática nos basta con leer
te solamente un artículo de cambios y
decir que ya eres una persona
completamente renovada y cambiada no los
cambios requieren esfuerzo requieren
disciplina pero sobre todo requieren que
tengamos las ganas de querer hacerlo y
la mayor parte del tiempo no estamos
dispuesto a hacerlo y llega en el peor
de los casos cuando tocamos fondo
pero ahora yo les pregunto a ustedes qué
es tocar fondo
no es más que un momento crucial y
crítico en nuestras vidas en donde
debemos parar reflexionar y entender que
la vida nos está diciendo a gritos es
hora de cambiar lo que está esperando
por ti del otro lado es muchísimo mejor
de lo que estás viviendo hoy si lo vemos
como una oportunidad podemos crecer y
salir adelante con una actitud ganadora
pero ahora veamos si esto de los cambios
es posible
hoy me siento sumamente orgullosa y
feliz de poder compartirles un pedazo de
mi historia que no me define que es
parte de mí y que me marcó mucho en
donde si yo no hacía grandes cambios en
mi vida lo que venía para mí no iba a
hacer nada bueno
cuando yo llegué a la edad de 30 años yo
llevaba 8 años de mi vida de mi vida
viviendo en los excesos sin darme cuenta
ya yo me encontraba sumergida en ellos
cada día que pasaba
yo perdía más mis valores mis principios
mis sueños mis buenos hábitos y ni
hablar de mi propósito de vida si en ese
momento ustedes me preguntaban cuál era
mi propósito de vida no sabría qué
responderles porque no me conocía dice
un gran físico de la historia albert
eisntein conocer a los demás
este inteligentes conocerse a sí mismo
es de sabios y la verdad es que yo
llevaba un completo desorden en mi vida
no me conocía
nunca me impute en todo ese tiempo en
conocerme y entender que era lo que yo
quería para mi vida pero algo un día
ocurrió algo inesperado algo de la cual
en ese momento yo no lo veía como una
oportunidad más bien yo lo veía como
otro problema más para mi vida
y fue entonces cuando voy notando que mi
barriga va creciendo
y si para mi sorpresa estaba embarazada
se podrán imaginar 8 años viviendo en
los excesos yo no estaba preparada para
ser madre
ni mucho menos lo quería en ese momento
fue una de las situaciones más difíciles
que yo he confrontado en mi vida porque
mire mi realidad y note que no tenía
absolutamente nada que ofrecerle a ese
bebé que venía en camino no tenía dinero
no tenía un lugar no tenía nada en mi
mente no tenía nada en mi corazón no
tenía nada en mi espíritu
fueron semanas donde yo no hacía más que
llorar y repetirme la clásica pregunta
porque a mí porque a mí dios mío ahora
yo pueda entender que esa es una actitud
bastante típica de las personas víctimas
de sus circunstancias cuando no desean
afrontar su realidad todo lo externo
tiene la culpa ellos nunca la tienen no
son responsables
recuerdo que cuando mi bebé tenía 8
meses de vida ya conmigo yo aún seguía
sintiéndome vacía y peor aún no tenía
nada que ofrecerle
y fue entonces cuando decidí tener la
primera conversación honesta y real
conmigo misma me interesé en conocerme a
mí misma
me di cuenta que todas las preguntas que
me hacía iban a dar todas a la misma
dirección que yo necesitaba cambiar mis
hábitos mis pensamientos y actitudes y
una de las preguntas que me movió
muchísimo a tomar acción para que todos
esos cambios y hábitos empezarán a pasar
fue la siguiente
liliana que se requiere de ti para que
seas una mujer renovada emprendedora
exitosa
saludable que te ames y te respetes que
se requiere de ti liliana vamos que se
requiere
y nuevamente entendía que eran mis
hábitos mis actitudes y mis pensamientos
me di cuenta que no necesitaba dinero ni
de nada material para que mis cambios
empezaran a ocurrir todos venían de aquí
adentro todos venían de mí
así que recuerdo que empecé a meterme en
la lectura y el primer libro que me leí
fue la fuerza de creer de wayne dyer un
libro sumamente poderoso que me ayudó a
abrir mi mente a que si yo creía
firmemente en lo que yo quería y tomando
acciones comprometidas yo podía lograr
mis cambios
y empezará a ver esa mujer soñada
así que a la brevedad empecé a tomar
acción y recuerdo que simplemente tres
grandes cambios en mi vida el primer
cambio que hice fue cambiar todos mis
pensamientos negativos como también esas
actitudes de víctima que tenía y me
seguía haciendo otras preguntas y una de
ellas que también fue muy poderosa para
mí es como no tengo nada es que entonces
voy a descubrir para que soy buena y eso
se llama conocerse a uno mismo
el conocerme a mí misma me permitió
descubrir mi propósito de vida de ayudar
a las personas en su crecimiento
personal como también me empoderó a mí
para la nueva batalla y desafío que yo
tenía ser una buena madre y una mujer
completamente renovada y empoderada
lo segundo que hice fue llenar y nutrir
mi espíritu empecé a creer en algo estoy
lleno 'enormemente mi vida y mi corazón
de paz y tranquilidad lo tercero que
hice fue hacer una limpieza de mi
entorno fíjense todas esas personas y
cosas que ya no están en la misma
sintonía de echar para adelante
también todas mis notificaciones de mis
redes sociales de fiestas por eventos
motivacionales como también empecé a
seguir personas de éxito que ya lo
tuvieran en las áreas que yo no los
estaba teniendo el hacer una limpieza de
mi entorno ayudó a que yo hiciera mis
metas con enfoque y dirección
teniendo ya estos grandes cambios en mi
vida entonces empieza a tomar sentido
y en ese proceso descubrí que la vida
tiene grandes tesoros para todos
nosotros sí grandes muy grandes pero la
vida quiere que salgas y que emprendas
ese camino que vivas tu proceso y que
elijas los cambios significativos que
tienes que hacer en tu vida y la vida te
va a dar lo que siempre te ha
pertenecido
y quiero que noten algo mis cambios no
tuvieron nada que ver ni con las
personas ni cosas a mi alrededor el
mundo no cambió para que yo cambiara
todo siguió igual la que tuvo que
cambiar y tomar acción fui yo
hoy llevo 5 años tomando lo que es mío
lo que me pertenece lo que siempre ha
estado ahí para mí mi familia mi vida mi
tiempo mi propósito de vida
pase de ser una mujer que vivió ocho
años en los excesos ahora a ser una
mujer empoderada saludable y
emprendedora
ahora yo les pregunto ustedes creen que
es posible cambiar
honestamente yo no quisiera que nadie
pasara 8 años de su vida perdidos porque
simplemente hoy no pueden tomar la
decisión de hacer cambios significativos
en sus vidas
hoy con seguridad y validez les puedo
decir dos cosas lo primero es que tu
pasado no te define así que sal y
demuestra con hechos tus cambios y lo
segundo que te puedo decir es que si lo
crees en tu mente lo crearás con el
corazón y serás imparable muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]